[Music]
show me something time week 17 playoff
spots on the line seating still at play
and also futures to be either secured or
squandered based upon what happens this
weekend all right chris the time has
come for you to call the coin toss and
then ultimately the rigged system will
result in you getting the first pick as
you always do okay well you know i'm
going tails okay i can't see my monitor
today it's not working here so you guys
are not going to tell them heads want to
that's what is it stats it's heads ah
darn it
no it's actually tails oh yeah it's
tails
go ahead you get the first pick okay i'm
thanks for trying stats i'm starting i
know stats you just you're out of the
trust tree no longer are you there the
circle of trust you're out that's one
tree out with you i never want to be in
that tree i don't know i don't know you
never know one of the branches gonna be
on fire all right go ahead
okay i'm gonna start out with one of
your favorites for the old holiday
special you know who i'm picking number
one
the whole titans organization here we go
there we go bam yeah you've spent the
last two hours trashing the titans and
now you're gonna try to suck up no i'm
not going to try to suck up them i'm
just trying to tell them that they got
to show me something because i don't
think you're a playoff caliber football
team okay and you're going to have to
prove it to me this week and beating
andrew luck and the indianapolis colts
on sunday night football there's nothing
elite about that football team on the
tennessee titans there's a lot of good
there's a lot of solid i don't see any
area that i look at and go elite i don't
look at any one player and go that's
elite and there are
what they haven't beat andrew luck in
his as a starting quarterback since he's
been the quarterback of the indianapolis
colts come on tennessee titans you got
to show me something there uh so yeah
they're gonna have to show it to me to
to make me believe that they're a true
playoff team and that they deserve to be
in i don't give a damn if it's blaine
gabbard or marcus marietta i think
they're in trouble against the colts and
andrew luck is elite and that offensive
line is elite and that's why i think
they're going to win the football game
but let's see if the tennessee titans
can show me and tell me to shut up
well i hope on saturday night mike
frable takes the last minute and a half
and plays it for his team of course most
of them are going to be like who's that
guy so it won't have quite the same
impact oh thank you you're very nice who
are those guys let me throw myself into
that same thing for yourself
but but here's the thing i i believe in
that i've gone back and forth just in
the last hour and a half you had me
convinced that the colts will win the
game but i i feel like for one game and
one game only mike vrable can get the
titans on the right page look at how
derek henry has performed the past few
weeks i don't care if it's blaine
gabbard i'm starting to believe
tennessee titans are gonna find a way to
win this football game and and and the
fact that you believe they have no one
who is elite at his respective position
it just tells me that this is a team
it's a team sport they pull together the
sum of the parts is greater than the
whole or whatever the cliche is the
bottom line is they're better as a team
than they are individually and that may
be why we don't look at any of them as
elite it doesn't matter if any is elite
what matters is who has more points when
the game's over yep that's right thank
you for trying to put holes into my pick
there now go ahead with yours so i can
do the same to you
well i think you know what my pick is
gonna be here you know me fairly well
now we've been colleagues and friends
for over a year can i guess what
go ahead
um i think you're going to pick a
quarterback that wears a purple jersey
lamar jackson no not that one same
number
kurt cousins
kurt you got to stop being kurt you got
to be kirk this weekend because when
you're curt it doesn't work we saw this
two years ago when washington was facing
a win and in week 17 scenario against
the giants who weren't playing for their
playoff lives washington was and kirk
was curt in that game and now this year
where the vikings have had multiple
high-profile failures and look this was
a tough schedule one of the toughest
schedules that any team would have had
this year when you consider where they
had to play when they had to play how
the games were strung together prime
time big spots and the vikings are still
alive but they're going to have to prove
it this weekend against a team that is
still playing for the number two seed in
the nfc they'll be doing some scoreboard
watching over what the rams do and if
the rams are losing to the 49ers the
bears will be bringing it because if
they can get that bye week that is huge
if they can force the rams to come back
to chicago that is even bigger so this
is going to be kirk cousins hopefully
for him not playing like kurt so kurt
show me that you're really kirk and do
it this weekend yeah i've uh i mean it's
hard to push back against that i get it
i hate about it and it's always about
the quarterback you know me i mean i
don't like that we always make it just
about the one guy
when you know their offensive line
hasn't been great and they haven't run
the football and they're certainly going
to need all those aspects as well this
week to beat the chicago bears but hey
here's the thing yeah the guy could have
picked the guy was a free agent right he
picked this team yeah he's right this
spot and he helped him for more money
and now yes he's got to deal with it i
get it and this he it's on him right to
live up to the 28 million per year that
he's getting and this is his chance this
is his moment this is what the vikings
have paid for and if he fails in this
spot then the decision to sign him
fairly can be called a failure yeah i i
get you i'm not going to go failure
failure yet but he did make this bed and
when you make 28 million dollars a year
or a little north of that you're
certainly going to invite some criticism
when you don't play well and your team
that went 13-3 last year doesn't make
the playoffs this year so i totally get
that okay i'm going to another
quarterback in the same color jersey you
said his name before but i'm going lamar
jackson just because i don't want to
pick an organization or offense but
lamar jackson's got a chance on sunday
to
inject his team into the playoffs and
make them the asc north champions and
more importantly officially end the joe
flacco era in baltimore and really just
leave no questions for the future just
just say hey i'm the franchise
quarterback i brought us here down the
stretch with some clutch wins and big
wins and playoff type football whether
that was in kansas city or
i know they lost in kansas city but he
played very well or in los angeles last
weekend against one of the best teams in
football where hey when they needed big
throws lamar jackson delivered and he's
going to have to do that again this
weekend because i don't think the
cleveland browns are just going to roll
over for the baltimore ravens lamar
jackson going to have to continue to
play yes
good football running it but just make
those handful of plays in the pass game
that he's done in most of their vic
victories where yeah okay it's not
precision like we're gonna go oh he's 40
or 50 for 400 yards but the quality of
some of his completions are huge whether
they're you know
62-yard bombs last week when oh no the
chargers kind of got control of the game
back bam he throws a touchdown to mark
andrews it changes the game but here's a
chance of lamar lamar jackson to control
that organization and really have a
whole city and fan base behind him with
a win on sunday
yeah and i'm going to stay in that same
game because i understand that lamar
jackson is a rookie quarterback is
trying to prove that he can deliver a
playoff berth and cement his role as the
starter and i think it's cemented
regardless of what happens i think the
only way that his status is in jeopardy
is if he gets injured in this game joe
flacco comes in and wins it and then joe
flacco sparks a postseason run if lamar
jackson can't play but this is for baker
mayfield this is a huge game because
this is an opportunity to put a great
final touch on an unexpectedly strong
season finish on the right side of 500
after being owen 16 last year after
laboring under hugh jackson for the
entire offseason training camp preseason
and multiple weeks almost half of the
regular season for baker mayfield to be
able to will this team to a victory in a
spot where they have nothing to gain
other than the satisfaction of winning
the last game of the season that leads
to nothing beyond the regular season
this is the thing that i think will put
the browns justifiably so on the short
list of great teams for 2019 and great
teams beyond that and it will lock in
four or more prime time games for them
next year and it really does set the
stage for the browns to get
a truly great coach for next year
somebody who can take them to the super
bowl year one and i don't know who it's
going to be but i think that there are
going to be a ton of coaches out there
that want this job and with each victory
that the browns get i think it becomes
more attractive and this is an
opportunity for mayfield to take home
the rookie of the year award i think if
he wins this game he gets the offensive
rookie of the year award and it's an
opportunity for the browns to really
send a message to everyone else that you
better watch out for cleveland in 2019.
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay i like
everything you said there except the
rookie of the year award that's already
been given to saquon barkley sorry gonna
have to disagree with you there
all right we'll see if baker mayfield
wins this game on sunday i think
mayfield's the mvp you'd give it to him
not the mvp the rookie yeah right you'd
give it to him though over saquon you
you you would okay all right yes man i
just i i know rookie has had a bigger
impact on his team in the first year i
since maybe ben roethlisberger in 20 in
2004 when he ended up starting most of
the the games and they went 15-1 well
okay yeah you're what you're just
talking about being maybe adrian
peterson in 2007. okay all right i mean
i think saquon's impact impact on a team
yeah impact on a team to and even though
they're not making to the playoffs to
take them from owen 16 they won one game
in two years they may win eight games
this year yeah eight times the number of
victories in one season over the last
two that that and and i don't know we've
gotten numb to that like we get numbed
to patrick holmes throwing four
touchdowns yeah right but i think that
we need to take it seriously no he's
awesome he's definitely in that cava i'm
not going to give it to him over saquon
barkley you know the guy that's
third in the league in rushing and
averaging 4.9 yards per carry behind an
offensive line that we all give the
excuse for the quarterback to go oh the
quarterback can't play good because the
offensive line's horrible but yet the
running back is amazing against that's
behind that same horrible offensive line
so that's where i just think uh saquon
goes to another level but either way i'm
not going to argue with your pick there
i think you're uh pretty spot on all
right i'm staying with quarterback and
you know i don't really like to stay
quarterback and talk about them so much
but and i don't necessarily love this
topic either but it is a chance for show
me something and it's a chance uh for
nick foles that's who i got to go with
with my third round pick just because
hey yeah he's shown me some stuff but he
can really
show us a lot more here come week 17.
you beat the redskins you get in the
playoffs i mean he can put the eagles in
some tough spot he can of course
increase his own value across the league
after the year's over to become a
starter somewhere else and see if he's
really willing of that i don't think
he's ever as good as carson wentz i'll
never say that at no point but he's
certainly doing some big things and he's
playing a washington redskins team that
yes is out has josh johnson starting at
quarterback they had a dj swearinger
yelling at the you know coaching staff
after the game and they released him
this week nick foles has a chance to
show us all something not only that he
can lead this team into the playoffs
once again but that he's a true
nfl starting caliber quarterback and i
think that question
in my mind has still not been answered i
really don't i think he's a fringe
starter you know backup kind of per se
there um but if he wins this one and
they get in the playoffs and win another
one or two it's hard for me to deny that
he is a starter and needs to be
somebody's main guy next year
yeah look i understand what you're
saying i just don't think this is the
week for it because he's already beaten
the rams he's already beaten the texans
we expect him to beat washington and i
don't think that win or lose it really
is going to change much he needs to get
to the playoffs so he needs to win and
hope for the vikings to lose and then
continue in the postseason to do the
things he's been doing as you were
setting that up i thought you were going
to take the guy that i've been squatting
on that i that i think is far more
relevant and will deliver victory to me
in this show me something draft and that
is a quarterback who hasn't played in a
long time and will be playing
extensively on sunday for the new
orleans saints and that's teddy
bridgewater prime opportunity for him to
come back and look like the guy he was
before that devastating knee injury in
early 2016 before the regular season
even started wiped out all of 2016
almost all of 2017 and now he's been on
the bench in new orleans he gave a third
round pick to get him as the backup to
drew brees he's going to walk away as a
free agent and with guys like justin
herbert saying i'm not coming to the nfl
teddy bridgewater's potential goes up
and this is his chance to show us all
something as we get ready to figure out
who the top candidates for free agency
quarterback contracts will be
bridgewater i think has a lot more to
gain on sunday than falls because falls
has already gained plenty of the last
two weeks yeah i i mean uh bridgewater
certainly has something to gain you're
right about that there's no
we want to see is he even close to the
guy he was before the knee injury you
know what's he capable on the field and
yeah is he capable of being that guy
you're talking about which is starting
for another football team next year
whether they want to make him the guy
going forward or the holdover guy
because they drafted somebody either way
i think it's very similar to nick foles
like i don't think the nfl is
necessarily necessarily sitting here
going oh nick foles is definitely a
starter next year because he's proven to
me the last we got to go ahead
i
we got to take a break i was giving you
the wrap it up i forgot you couldn't see
me we'll be back with more pfd elaborate
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports